you know there's an achievement in
mortal combat for spilling 10,000 pints
of blood pretty sure this movie would
have gotten that a few times over
seriously it's crazy 300 rise of an
empire so 300 rise of an empire is a
sequel to 300 but I saw they were making
those like do they really have to make
that I mean it's not even based on
source material but I found out it's
actually based on Frank Miller's working
project circ C's which expands the world
of 300 and shows more about Xerxes elzar
okay that's source material I'm not
saying not being based on source
material is gonna make it I'm just
saying I had a little more faith in the
movie after I found out about that but I
still went into this movie cautious and
oh that is movie pretty happy first
of all this movie being a sequel of 300
doesn't actually explain it it's more of
a parallel event rise of an empire
starts out before 300 and then 300 is
happening while this movie's taking
place and then 300 rise of an empire
ends after 300 it's like 300 s wedged in
the middle of this whole thing but this
movies actually spans a longer amount of
time first of all you have all the
action you had in 300 but it's a
different tone the Spartans were cool to
watch because I like Klingon so like
death and glory and we die in the
battlefield with honor and that is
glorious Sparta the Athenians don't
really like that I like all my friend
died this sucks ass I don't like my
friend dying in the battlefield this is
it's cool to look up to the
Spartans but the other greatest they're
more relatable like yeah that I would
react more like that if my friend died
in the battlefield I wouldn't be like ah
he's the lucky one and the main guy in
this movie Themistocles I believe that's
how you say his name - mr. Cleese
Themistocles I just saw the movie I
can't remember
it's a Greek name they are difficult I
hope I'm not true vaulting right here
but I believe it's Themistocles I doubt
Kazim fellows worried
this dude is badass these guys don't
fight with the Phalanx like the Spartan
so this guy just charges in it he
reminds me of Achilles this is no
stopping this guy this guy he's got all
the moves and we have ourselves a really
vicious in this movie played by
Eva green this chick she was awesome she
was a great villain she was sexy she was
the biggest cut bag this side of Lena
Headey from Dredd it's true if that word
offends you I'm sorry but if you watch
this movie you will walk out going yet
she was a it's just the word that
describes her she was so good at it I
like a good villain in a movie did you
go look at 300 and say less the simple
approach it has a simple lesson freedom
is worth fighting for and worth dying
for 300 rise of an empire has a
different lesson and that is hell hath
no fury like a woman scorned who
possesses a large Persian naval army and
unlimited resources the things that
bothered me about this movie is first of
all the green screen is a lot more
noticeable in this there were a couple
times where you see the green haze
around the mystic Liza's beard you're
like yo man this is millions of dollars
that's supposed to happen with me
because I'm just me on YouTube no I
Hollywood movies and the blood looked
fake the blood supposed to look fake
because it's stylistic it's gonna be CGI
blood flying everywhere that it was that
way in 300 also but I thought the blood
and 300 looked realer than 300 rise of
an empire and and this shouldn't bother
me but when movies do this it does
everything is tied together you see
people in this movie that are tied to
the first 300 movies somehow are you
telling me that this situation in this
person in this movie somehow tied back
to that person in the last movie it's
like that with a lot of people I'm like
the world's not that small it's okay to
make up characters and say yeah this
person just had to do with this has
nothing to do with the last movie
doesn't have to granted I like Easter
eggs so that's fine we're here to have
fun it's a 300 movie you're not supposed
to take it too seriously so in the end
300 rise of an empire was a really fun
movie it held to the same feeling as the
first 300 movie it had its own angle
that it took showing the Greeks actually
doing their thing it had a great hero it
had a great villain I walked out of this
movie going that was pretty cool I will
say 300 rise of an empire is a great
time no alcohol required I'd actually
like to see a super edit of 300 we have
300 rise of an empire with 300 edited
into it so it's actually one big movie
bouncing back and forth between the two
movies it's like one three and a half
hour epic that'd be pretty sweet you
know it would be it's a 300 rise of an
empire have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]